Hi, I'm Mano.
I'm gonna be speaking
with Keith and Jeff
about building
scalable GeoWeb applications
at Google I/O.
Over the last five years,
there's been an explosion
of Web-based
geographic applications,
which we often call the GeoWeb.
The growth of these applications
has been driven by such tools
as Google Maps API
and Google Earth.
These tools take care of the
front end of the deployment--
the complex job of putting
the right map tiles
in front of the right people.
However, developers
who have a rich spatial data set
have to build the back ends for
these applications themselves.
When these applications
scale up
with tons of data
and lots of users,
Geo Developers have to become
Web server architects,
sharding their databases,
balancing the loads
between servers,
and spending a fair amount
of money, and lots of time,
just to have their applications
continue to run.
In this talk, we'll talk about
what are the problems
of scalability,
what are some
of the approaches,
and what Google offers
in a way of data hosting
that is useful
for spatial data.
Specifically,
we'll talk about Google Base,
Google App Engine,
and the really exciting
new Google Maps data API,
which uses the standard
Google Data API set
based on Atom Pub.
So here's the basic code.
This is Atom Pub.
Anybody who's familiar with it
will recognize this.
This is posting an entry
to edit a link
of an existing feature
in Google Maps.
You'll see here
you've got your atom entry.
You've got title and content.
These are all familiar to you
if you've used Atom Pub
or any of the Google Data APIs
which are based on Atom Pub.
Then you'll see "Placemark,"
and that's
in the KML name space.
Maps Data API reuses KML.
It's really exciting.
A lot of people
have been talking about this.
How do you integrate,
you know, restful applications
with KML?
And here we are.
"Description, style, point"--
These are just standard KML.
You're just posting
a Placemark.
And that's it.
That's all you have to do.
So we're gonna go over this
and a lot more during the talk,
and I really look forward
to seeing you.
Hope you can make it.